this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'll be talking about transcriptome
analysis in between under service stress
today which is a big part of my PhD and
I want to start off this talk by
introducing the problem with self stress
talking briefly about particular
mechanism that plants used to cope with
7ad introducing you a great new model to
study some stress which is petunia
briefly talk about genomics in different
species and then briefly mention about
advantages of using RNA seek technology
then I want to well give through the
experimental design and I want to spend
most of the time talking about the
result which I broke down into RNA seek
without reference genome and expanding
result with a reference genome so I saw
the stress it is a big problem worldwide
there's not surprised about that you can
see in this map all this red color that
are pretty widespread throughout the
world represent five grams of sodium
chloride per liter which is equivalent
to 90 milli molar sodium chloride is a
pretty pretty big amount of salt pretty
white express widespread in the world we
also see that twenty percent of the
irrigation water is have affected by
solar stress so why is this a problem
well salinity and rosters are the
primary causes of crop loss world 1n
sodium chloride actually it is what
disrupt the normal prime growth and
development this is a simple experiment
in which sodium chloride plant through
the wiltern chlorides I can show this
really [ __ ] phenotype compared to
the control now the lonely there's not a
really long days of detrimental
consequences of sodium chloride I'm just
mentioned in a couple of here there's a
big disrupt in mineral nutrition
specifically with potassium and there's
also a more in a cytosolic level strong
inhibition in enzymes so when I talk
about sodium chloride at a cellular
level I basically mean sigh when in the
cytosol you find more than 100 milli
molar sodium chloride as opposed to less
than 10 milli molar in the cytosol but
likely for us plant have developed
different mechanism to cope with stress
and and there's again a really long list
of coping mechanism I'm just showing you
here five which is restriction
set of celeb take extrusion incomparable
ization controlling the long distance of
sodium for the stabilizing membranes and
increasing osmotic potential just as a
long list now so I brought this up
because it's an interesting cycle that
uses one or more of this coping
mechanism so sodium chloride in high
concentrations can be perceived by
unknown receptors which triggered the
elevation of cytosolic calcium a
secondary messenger that activates is
this protein receptor sauce 3 which
activates this kinase so stew which is
pretty much the kind is that does a lot
of the world in this mechanism by
phosphorylating displacement these
transporters during the plasma membrane
which actually extrude calcium pump
volume out of the cytosol this kindness
sauce tube as well can control the
expression of na x which is a tonoplast
transported the pump sodium into the
vacuole which was correspond to
compartmentalization one of the ways in
which sodium gets in the cytosol the
first place is by utilizing low affinity
potassium transport that you guys can
see down here and there's a big unknown
and there's a lot of research going on
to figure out how this complex chose to
so3 can down-regulate and stop the stop
this low affinity potassium transporter
and again there's a lot of unknowns we
don't know how these complex interacts
with the high-affinity potassium
transporter so this of course pathway
has been figured out in arabidopsis most
of the study that we we know today in
such stress as comfort at the office
which is a great model for a lot of
things but nobody foresaw the stress so
we are actually suggesting that we
should shift a little bit the pattern
with the Arab dogs is to petunia and why
do we study these leave is petunia and
Ursula stress it really deals pretty
well with our stress one percent of us
of sodium ions by driveway it is it can
accumulate one percent of its way in
sodium now we did this experiment in
2011 where we screen the ability of 14
species to withstand sodium chloride and
we group them in for in for big groups
the most tolerant species some were
tolerant sensitive and extremely
sensitive and you can see that petunia
actually runs in the most learn in the
most tolerant upper level now when you
grow up with unions under 60 40 20 milli
molar sodium chloride the really the
growth and the phenotype is not really
affected you see some detrimental
consequences at 80 millimolar normally
effect during flowering but just
returning the growth so we sing the
petunia can offer a really good can be a
really good model to further study
showing a defect of sodium chloride so a
petunia it is a it's one of the members
of the solar NASA family which is a
pretty many of these some nasty species
are great for genetics and biochemical
studies this is a these are the parents
of petunia hybrida axillaris and in
florida and i'm going to talk about this
later on later today and then we have
the distance with related tomato now
when we think about petunias the model
species the first thing that we actually
think about is it is a really good model
for transpose almost as good model as
maize for transporting element that's a
lot of cytogenetic analysis it is a
great model for pigmentation and floral
scent and four Vic's but but we're
pushing the opportunity as a model as
well for some stress now what has been
done in terms of solid stress in this
family well unfortunately there hasn't
been a lot of research conducted with
this Vanessa family made the most
thorough study the was published in 2007
was a microwave in tomato where they
occurring to accession of tomato this
one up here they stress the plan with
150 milli molar sodium chloride and they
only a sample would they microwave using
the microwaves day they were able to
identify roughly 100 EST s that were
differentially expressed at 30 minutes
of sodium chloride exposure 700e sts two
hours in 1000 st
at six hours and they were able to group
all these e sts into different group
using gene ontology such as energy
metabolism etc now this was a great
approach because you really change the
way that we approach the study sorry
Claude I looking single gene single
pathway to a more global holistic point
of view so so we're doing something
similar in fact the only difference is
that we're not we're not using or new
using these chips anymore we're actually
using an RNA seek approach and the
reason that we decided to do this way is
because our microwaves we're great
technologies in the early 2000s however
they are a relatively low throw food
they really depend on sequencing of cdna
NE estis libraries they can be expensive
and not container a quantitative they
they do have a false positive to cross
hybridization and they have a really
small dynamic range that is to say
transcript better load transcript
transcript that transcribe lilo in
really high they're not going to be
picked by the microwave so instead we
decided to use a more novel technique
RNA sig which is a really high
throughput approach where you can
sequence millions of nucleotides of DNA
in a single run it is cheaper compared
to a microwave it has a really good
dynamic range you don't it has more
sensitive sensitivity than the microwave
and has a better coverage so this is the
float the flow as to how we we actually
do the library preparation but I'm not
gonna go over that and this is a
protocol developed by James Devon only
the bti which I'll talk about in a few
minutes okay so what are the goals of
this project we wanted to characterize a
transcriptional profile of petunia
hybrida under some stress 150 milli
molar and control we wanted to develop a
transcriptional profiles through a time
course of gene expression and we aim as
well to understand how biological
processes change it with our stress for
the specific goes which I'm going to get
later today we wanted to compare using
our own ASIC platform how to hold in
expression changes with and without
reference genome so how do we set up the
experiment
we had a team plants grown
hydroponically in a growth chamber which
were randomly divided into two groups
these are nine plants corresponding to
control which i color-coded with dark
green and nine plants corresponding to
the the treated plants with 150
millimolar now when you do our n seek
and when you do basically any type of
science it is really good to do by
rebbe's and that's what we did we pull
one leaf from three plants will become
one bio replicate so we have red one red
two red three and we will do this this
time points 06 and 24 hours after solar
stress and we would do it at both at
both control and treatment to control
for circadian genes or genes that are
mechanically induced that we're not
really interested in looking so we did
this for root for root for lives in this
series disability experiment a lot of
RNA to extract from different tissues so
we decided to focus on leaves to begin
with and we left route for later on so
we did all the live at the beginning and
at these three time points 6 20 and 24
and as I said at the beginning we use
this protocol developed BTW i buy
joanna's group where we struck 12 our
name with the trifle method we captured
messenger RNA with magnetic beads which
we reverse transcribed to cdna and then
at this stage of the CDI next stage we
index the library with the six with a
barcode six nucleotide barcode with hplc
primers which would give us an index at
library so so this is the way that the
protocol works this is an already
optimized protocol now as we were doing
this realize that ordering or hplc
primers it was quite expensive so we
said well what happens if we indexes
libraries with knowledge plc program so
so in this case for example we have this
tool indexed libraries one of them with
this set of primary one of this with
this set of primer all of the incoming
from the same pool of RNA alright so
they would be really the same except for
the code the six nucleotide code and we
did this little side experiment with all
the leaves to optimize this protocol by
assessing
hplc vs. knowledge plc would have an
effect in a library preparation why did
we bother to do that well because if
they are actually the same we can treat
these libraries as technical replicates
increasing the depth of our experiment
and of course if we prove that this
doesn't really affect the data is a big
advantage for future our next experiment
so we we did this for all the libraries
all the leaks libraries from these three
time points generating 30 libraries
corresponding to both technical in
biological replicates we pair in
sequence in a single line to rule out
any line primary effect in a high c 2000
and we generated 196 million read so so
how do we how do we go about how do we
go about to do our own a cig with all
this 196 million with that we just
generated with the illuminant Isaac so
the first question that we asked was
regarding to the hplc uhplc primers was
okay are those sample the same if they
were not then we'll just discard on hplc
samples and we will proceed Darren asic
without them now in our case and I'll
show you that they actually doesn't
really matter we they were the same so
we proceeded to demultiplex and we
process we got rid of the alumina
adapters we increase the q value of the
root etc and then we work with this
clean basically clean grid now the
second question that we had to us is
well do we have a reference genome that
we can align all the shore it's against
so if you have a reference genome that
Greg you just can proceed to map and
then look for gene expression if you
don't have you need to assemble generate
a consensus and then you go back to
mapping once you Matt generate a bump
file and then you can count based the
ribs which is the basics of our own a
stick and gene expression and I'm going
to get to this part later on so going
back to this first question are these
samples the same or not so it turns out
that it doesn't really matter whether
you use hplc or non hplc primers so this
is a hit map of differentially expressed
genes in which you are looking at how
the sample clustered together so we're
basically comparing the biological
replica
are one or two or three versus the
technical replicates NH and hplc and you
see that all the distance between the
diff some between the technical
replicates a P and n NH it is a smaller
than biological reps so I'm just going
to sleep I'm just going to assume into
this heat map to show you that
fortunately this is so this says are too
so all the technical replicates HP and h
NH HP are more closely related than the
biological replicates so these and you
see this across all the samples so there
was a great indication that really it
doesn't really matter whether you use
hplc knowledge plc now the final in most
strong evidence to argue that you can
use knowledge plz primer it came from
the statistical analysis where we run a
multiple analysis of variance between
these two data set and in our in our
statistical model we include primer type
hplc uhplc time point 06 and 24 and
interaction of dose it will look at the
cut off of the most expressed transcript
at ten hundred thousand ten thousand and
one hundred thousand RPM and here I'm
just showing you the output for the
expression profile of the top 10 most
express transcript and you can see that
both treatment and time points are
significant as well as the interaction
of treatment and time point but primer
themselves they actually they're not
significant so with this data we were
able to conclude that we can and we
should treat our libraries our knowledge
TLC and hplc as technical replicates and
I has the great impact that can be by
decreasing the cost of library
preparation for future I realistic
experiment um so great that was a but
that wasn't my research that was a
little side project that we had going on
the real research it was to do RNA sit
with petunia under such stress and the
question then becomes how do we hide
away struck biological information from
this weed and the first problem that I
had is that there's already 60 plant
genome sequence unavailable this
some of them are adopted errata polyanna
of course models we have maze over here
there's a couple of Savannah's tomato in
potato but there's no petunia so in the
era of next-generation sequencing you
have to have a reference to align your
wrist so how do you how do you go about
if you don't have a reference so it
turns out that there is a way there is a
way to do this which is by generating a
transcript owned by the novel assembling
all the millions of reads that you
generated with Illumina sequencing into
one final transcriptome this is of
course a very simplified example but and
then we would we would basically treat
this will basically treat this
transcript term as if it was a genome
right it is not a genome but we will use
it in the same way to map so how do we
do this step there's different type of
assemblers nowadays that can allow you
to do these the first three assembler
mayra GS assembler and I assembler they
they basically rely on overlapping DNA
sequences and looking for consensus and
they are actually more suitable when you
have long reads for my experiment what I
have show rates of DNA I so then we
would look at this for assemblers down
here trust alleys so velvet and Trinity
which they don't really rely on this
overlapping consensus sequences they
rely on really complex mathematical
algorithm based on the bruijn graph to
generate a transcriptome so the way we
did this it'll be chose the three of the
the newest assembler Trinity soap and
trans others and we generated three
independent transcriptomes and we would
evaluate which of the transcriptome
would give us a would be the best and
induced a transcript or for downstream
analysis so so here we're looking at the
comparison of the messenger RNA length
distribution of the differential script
different assemblers we use compared
with tomato so we didn't plot transcript
longer than five thousand base pairs
because otherwise this box body would
have been huge and so here we have the
tomato transcriptome which we know then
and size is roughly 1,000 base pairs for
all for all the transcript and when
using Trinity with default cane or 25 we
obtain a really close distribution to
tomato which was closer than any of
these other three now soap with camer 47
it was good was the second-best getting
close to tomato but it wasn't as good as
Trinity and soap with the fold it wasn't
really it wasn't really good and trans
Abby's was the worse it didn't really
recover most of the transcript so so he
was great and this allow us to to see
that Trinity it was divest the noble
assembler now we also looked at buying
4matic parameters to make sure that
Trinity was indeed the best assembler
and when we look at continent-sized of
all the assemblers 20 was by far the
best it was almost to us the countries
were almost twice as big of any others
of the assemblers we had a pretty big l
50 and we have a really low in 50 which
is basically an indication as to how
fraction has to how cut off the
transcription can be so the lower the
m50 the better the only really bizarre
thing that we observed it was with that
we found we identify over 100,000
unigenes with this de novo assembly and
that was really personal because we know
what this stage we don't know how many
genes petunia has but we know that
tomato has roughly 35,000 so between yer
there's no way that Petula has more more
than more twice as that unless they're
crazy duplication gene events which is
really unlikely so this was interesting
and I'm going to get to that in a couple
of minutes but anyway we went ahead and
we annotated this transcript on that we
developed using a blast to go and bust
ago actually uses the NCBI database to
do all the blocks and the notation he
wasn't really good and I spent a lot of
time trying to figure out why the
notation wasn't wasn't really good and
then I realized that well the tomato
genome is actually non on NCBI so I was
doing the blast against all the other
species except tomato so then we re
annotated the same transcript on again
the sd's the sgn database is a database
exclusively for someone a CEA's that is
run a bt i so i relocated using a blast
x against the sgn database an annotation
was actually way better so we were able
to annotate roughly thirty three
thousand unigenes and this 32,000 map
directly to the coding region of tomato
with an average average size of roughly
1 kb we identify ribosomal proteins a
few bacterial genes and large majority
of the genes were unannotated we think
that they correspond to variable 5 prime
and 3 prime UTR regions that are unique
to petunia that are normally conserved
with tomato and as you might recall from
the beginning between it's a great model
for transposons in within that we're
actually capturing a lot of that here
now I want to keep in mind as well that
we have this a big number of unique
genes and that's because multiple judy
genes can correspond to one gene so this
is simple example in which we have a
gene with four exons and assuming that
this gene doesn't have any any isoform
this is the old isoform we would see
that the same correlation of the exons
in the transcript and when we map we see
enough coverage of read to data line to
x 1 1 and 2 but we do not see enough
coverage from exxon to to exon 3 in the
same from x + 3 and x 4 so basically the
software which is pretty smart but it's
not a smart enough it is thinking that
these are actually three independent
jeans so this also explain why we get a
big numbers now this big number it is
it's been reported other people that
have done or de novo assembly in other
species in chinese college for example
find a similar number of villages which
was surprising so anyway we decided to
use gene ontology to assign function to
all this de novo assembly transcript
that we were able to annotate and fifty
percent when you look at the unique
genes distribute
fifty percent of those are related with
both metabolic in cellular processes in
twenty twenty percent of the the overall
distribution correspond to response to
stimulus and biological regulation now
we uploaded this transcript on trust
this transcript to can be a great tool
for by pragmatic purposes so we decided
to share this we have loaded as a FTP
file in the in the sole genomic data
base and after a few weeks that we
publish this work we actually got a lot
of email from people asking if we could
make this blast of all so whatever
favorite gene that were working with
they could blast it again the
transcriptome so we contact people that
this gene and request that if they could
do a blast of all so that was pretty
cool so this is you can go now to the
SDN to a transcription project this is
our work and you can type whatever
partial sequence that you have for your
favorite gene and see if you can
retrieve more of the gene itself or the
annotation for it so that was pretty
cool and but again that wasn't the whole
purpose of the project the project it
was to do RNA seek to study some stress
but we needed to go through this de novo
assembly to find Oh to have all the
players to do rns-e so now we have we
have a reference in we can map we can
map using this software bowtie to to
look for gene expression when you do
this you generate a bump file and then
using artham you can count normal eyes
and look for reads per kilo ways of
action of read maps which is which is a
measure basically of gene expression and
then using this package in this
bioconductor this egg you can look for
differentially expressed genes so and
between these two things they are
peaking and the decks you spend a lot of
time doing the data mining now why do we
willing to data-mine so this is what you
get from using our same bioconductor it
is a pretty complex matrix of numbers
and it's really hard to to make sense of
it you can see this is for example
corresponds to leave when there were two
the good salt under 24 hours you see
all the RPM values our sin is bound with
Trinity so you can identify genes and
different I've I forms of the gene but
still this is not really intuitive you
could mix you can make absolutely no
sense of this and this is what your data
mine now what type of data mine method
do you use well double depends on the
type of research you're doing for our
case making sense of these hundred
thousand unigenes we decided to do look
for anomaly detection perform gene
ontology analysis class their analysis
and compare in compare basically our
data with a without a transcriptome
analysis I said I talked briefly about
this three today and so when we look at
anomaly detection you have to remember
that all the sequences were coming from
leaves right we left the roots at the
minus 80 at this point and this is a
when you do leave leaves you basically
would expect the Rubisco it is the most
abundant enzyme in the world you would
expect that the expression for this code
is the highest in both sub treated and
control lives and this is this is what
we saw while we observed that the top 10
most expressed genes in terms are taking
n were all related with the
photosynthesis in fact abisko it was the
highest now this date of course it's not
really interesting it just sort of to
validate there are an asic data you
don't do anything with this but it let
us know that we're on the right track
with the analysis so with the gene
ontology analysis we just aim to better
understand how biological processes are
affected we saw stress and so as I said
before we used in ontology to an to
assign function to this transcript but
the real question that we were looking
for it was how do these biological
processes change it we starting chloride
so we perform a statistical analysis
analysis Fisher test of gene ontology
turn differences where we would look for
the decks of coordinates of two time
points control six all six and will we
will compare those against our universe
which is the transcriptome now there are
different ways to talk about and where
and gene ontology I think that the world
cloud is one of the most simple one to
understand so just keep in mind that all
of these are over-represented go terms
that have a significant FBR that I'm not
showing but when we look at these two
time points control six and sound six we
see that we have abscisic acid and
ethylene are one of the most of the
represented go terms we also find
kindnesses in g protein-coupled
receptors as the most over-represented
go terms so all of these actually it
makes sense we know that kindness we
know that a BA in ethylene are the
stress hormones so we should of course
see another over-representation of those
we know that kinase and GPCRs are
crucial for signaling transduction
pathways then we're actually seeing
those findings salicylic acid it was
really interesting because this has been
reported with more plant pathogen
interaction so this is an interesting
cross talk between the biotic and
abiotic type of stress now the most
interesting and a part of the goat herb
analysis it was indeed it was that we
found 72 unique go terms associated
exclusively with 24 hours after some
stress so all these 72 unique go terms
were not found control six and when we
think about it actually makes sense
because at this at this stage cells have
been exposed to 24 hours sodium chloride
so you actually seen a lot of cellular
damage and the cells in cells are trying
to cope with it how do they do that one
way is that they produce lipid
biosynthesis the you can options you can
also see that there's a lot of glycerol
transport and you can also observe from
these go analysis that a cellular
biological process such as DNA
replication of DNA binding are highly
affected so I just want to bring this
slide from the very beginning to show
that even in this really short list of
consequences we were able with this with
this analysis to identifying how
membrane stabilization and osmotic
potential are represented here
now so these these analysis is what's
really useful for us to better
understand the biology of the cell of
stress and this of course is a really
brief brief summary so the last thing I
want to talk about with this first part
is the cluster analysis and so this is a
heat map we're using with the arts and
package again where we look at the
differentially expressed transcript
isoforms across the different time
points and ingrained you see upregulated
genes and write down regulated genes and
one of the interesting things about the
heat maps is that a clustering for that
matter is that it allows you to
identifying patterns of biological
interest so arson actually gives that it
gave us 12 cluster here and you can see
how they are related with this sideways
dendrogram in in the heat map you see
that this is a cell 6 cell 24 and the
three control which of course it makes
sense that the subclass or more closely
than the controls and when we look at
these clusters there were four clusters
that were highly interesting for me to
sub cluster 7 and 12 were at the very
bottom where you can see that under salt
there's a lot of green colors and under
control red color then we have a largest
cluster to in a small cluster up here
where you actually see what colors under
result in green colors under the control
so the interest so this can be confusing
but the interesting thing about
clustering is that we can now go and
soom into these clusters and look at the
profile of this genes that are behind
this so when we look at this a fork
subclass or the interest by looking at
South caster 12 and 7 the one that we're
at the very bottom of the heat map we
see that so each one of this gray line
correspond to a single transcript in the
blue one corresponds to a consensus of
the cluster we see that under the
control the expression of all these
genes is pretty low but when when South
hit the expression in South dr. 7 and 12
it goes dramatically up in fact we
identify that these three aggregates
transcript our chaplains over the world
induce
over 94 now and then these are this was
the largest sub cluster which wasn't
really interesting it does show an
increase in the in their expression upon
some stress but it's not nearly as
dramatic as these two cluster and
finally this was a interesting that we
all defined in this whole live
experiment 49 transcript that were
highly expressed under the control but
upon south treatment the expression
would go down dramatically now for our
purpose purposes of narrowing down to
Canada genes we looked at this this a
cluster which was the most interesting
for us and we had a DA transcript that
had a really interesting pattern that we
that we were interested in following and
they were interesting transcription
factor like this one but unfortunately
some of this gene had already been
described in literature so when we
decided to select a few candidate genes
we of course we narrow it down to those
ones that were not previously described
and so that led us this a discrimination
of this of this gene letters to narrow
it down to basically a candidate genes a
novel candidate genes that were not have
never been have never been described in
literature for solar stress and we group
these kind of the genes into two groups
basically those that were induced at
both time points south six and south 24
they were induced by several false
actually and the rest of the candidate
genes they were induced only at 24 hours
after celastrus so when we look at the
profiles of these are Canada genes I
just want to draw your attention right
right away to this one so so the
expression of these genes amazing it is
it is virtually zero under the control
but at six hours of solid stress it is
induced by 17 falls and at 24 hours of
some stress it is induced by almost 64
so this makes this gene really are
really interesting candidate and the
fact that it makes it also really
interesting is not that has a high
expression and induction but also is
unknown so we know that this gene Maps
the
regulo to chromosome 3 in tomato but we
were enabled we were not able to
retrieve any information about it we
know that it's not a chat room because
we would have able to retrieve that so
following up this genie would be really
really interesting so these other genes
are also highly expressed and induced
but not nearly as dramatic as a DS
unknown one and lastly the the last four
candidate genes that we selected they
were only highly induce and highly
expressed at 24 hours so these genes are
there are so sensitive genes that are
that are laid in the induction process
so lastly I want to say that a doing our
own a cig is great it allows us to
identify cluster genes understand a
little bit of the biology of a stress
but in order to make this kind of the
jeans official quote unquote you need to
do the characterization of them so so
what we did is that we order a few this
mutant one of the eight kind of the
genes that I just show you and by we
genotype trying to find the homozygous
that has the t-dna insertion in both
alleles and we were able this is only 11
Newton we were able to identify roughly
like five lines of homozygous line for
this for this genotype now following up
with this part of the research it really
takes time it is a long process and I
was running out of time so I'm going to
suggest that the next PhD student in
Neil's lab maybe have a really
interesting task to follow up this gene
especially the unknown one that's
another one it can definitely lead you
to a plant cell type of publication and
i also i also would like to say that the
next PhD student follow up with this
reverse genetic approaches screwing the
Newton's do in weeks as I said between
is a great model for weeks
complementation in planta overexpression
with 35's an inducible promoter and also
like a more broad type of research would
be interesting yet we looked at only one
a one cultivar mutual deploy but it will
be interesting to see if
order petunia hybrida perform in the
same way than this just to finish up
this section I'd like to say that pretty
much everything what I just mention it
was a publishing PLoS ONE the paper came
out a couple of weeks ago it was a big
collaboration between of course Neil
myself people in plant biology / Leon oh
who is actually now a faculty member at
Virginia Tech Mike Scanlon MGM's
giannoni and also I like to acknowledge
two of my colleagues Margaret Frank who
is now post dogging the down for Center
and Brian a maid who contributed with a
really thoughtful comments especially
Brian with a lot of statistical
consulting help so between all of them
we were able to publish this and we were
both excited about it and so the last
thing that I want to talk about is how
can we expand basically these results
now with the reference genome and
including root samples so the specific
goal for this it was to compare these
are using this platform aluminum within
without reference genome and I'll show
you this experimental design and I said
at the beginning that we focus firstly
on leaves so now we're including
everything we already have the sequence
for lips so we just needed to include
roots and the only different thing that
we use now is that that will use the
truxedo package so in this package
basically you map all the rates using
top hat that runs both high two in the
background to align all the ridge to the
chromosomes and then you use cufflinks
to look for all the language make them
into transcript and then we'd kind if
you can look at the expression so the
question is why did I bother to do all
the de novo assembly in the first place
if you have reference genome so as Neil
said at the beginning we didn't really
have a reference genome when we first
started but it wasn't until late
September that we started to collaborate
with the petunia Genome consortium which
allow us to use one of the versions
genome so very briefly the paternal
genome consortium it is a really big
effort between sigh
interest in both the US and Europe
basically the probably the most
important people are in BTW i Lucas in
orem we have people in Switzerland
crisco demeyere people in Italy and Tom
Jared's in the nether 1m as well as
Francesca so this was great because it
really allow us to use the genome as a
reference and that expand a whole lot
the way that we can do or na sequencing
basically so what are we specifically
doing with the between a genome project
I can't really say much because it
hasn't been published yet but one of the
things that I'm looking at is I'm
looking at molecular markers single
nucleotide polymorphism snips to assess
how many transcript are inherited from
each parent to Hibbert oh 440 tuxedo
analysis what we use it was this genome
the petunia axillaris dinner because the
both the functional and structural
annotation of the genome it was a
actually in better shape that in florida
so you can actually see that here we
have roughly thirty-six thousand genes
which is much less than the hundred
thousand that I find in the de novo
assembly but these using this genome as
by us by a 4matic resource it was a red
help so so when we run the analysis
using tuxedo and the reference genome we
found actually 34,000 genes which is it
much much more accurate than the hundred
thousand unique genes that we find with
the de novo we found 37,000 isoforms we
took 0 and 135,000 support with de novo
so basically there is no question that
running tuxedo it is a much more
accurate approach to do RNA sequencing
we identify 11 roughly 11,000
differentially expressed genes between
roots and leaves over million promoters
and over million splice insights when we
look at the tuxedo output out now one of
the things that is really interesting
with 20 is that you take everything into
our and into our you really can do
whatever you
do anything you want and I'd like to do
the analogy with the cell cycle because
do now racing it is really like the
cells the cell cycle where you have a
lot of checkpoint and if the checkpoint
has not been satisfied the cell cycle
stops so what the RNA sig is to really
the same so this is the first checkpoint
for us where we see how do the sample
cluster together so in this case in this
den program we see that we have two big
branches one corresponding to root in
one corresponding to leave so so this
makes sense because roots should be more
closely related to each other than
leagues so if you don't see this sort of
pattern there is something that went
wrong and you have to stop and go back
and in fact I had to do this twice
because one of the script that I wrote
it wasn't good so and when you look now
between this branch you see that the
control class are more closely together
done the cell treatment so so this is
this is a really good sign that you on
the right track when you look at the at
all the biological replicates and the
technical replicates here you see that
they also clustered together you see all
the live cell 24 cluster here so this is
again it's a good indication that that
you're doing things well when we look at
differentially expressed genes now we
took sedo we actually can we can confer
the look into leaves and roots and with
this tuxedo package we were able to
identify 6700 differentially expressed
genes some of them that were exclusively
expressed in this early time point some
of them were exclusively expressed in
this later time point and of course some
of these decks are expressed between
both time point and so with the de novo
assembly we were able to identify seven
thousand differential expressions which
wasn't that far off from what we
actually found here so that was pretty
cool and again with the same thing with
the roots their specific genes induced
at this time point and other time point
now as I said this is a still ongoing
research I don't have all the data that
like to show but whatever the thing that
I'm currently working on is see well how
many genes are differentially expressed
that are between leaf and roots so
that's going to be interesting
no lastly so I still need to do gene
ontology analysis for for tuxedo do the
clustering using these two software's
and and talk about candidate genes now I
don't have all the kinds of the genes
but we do have this one that it has a
really amazing profile that you can
actually see that the expression it
remains pretty flat actually zero in
leaves in even in route but only at
route cell 6 it is expressed over 100
RFP km induced 24 fold in route 24 it
isn't goodbye almost 80 falls so the
expression of this kinda gene is amazing
it is this is the ortholog in tomato I
need to still look the function of it
and then lastly I just want to wrap up
with some conclusions so we actually
develop a really novel transcriptome or
petunia hybrida and Ursula stress where
we identify over thousand different ab
related genes and through cluster
analysis we were able to narrow it down
to a candidate genes however using
tuxedo package either it's really a much
more accurate by 4matic tool that gives
us a better representation of gene
expression and differentially expressed
genes I'm still working on on finishing
up with this is a tuxedo package you add
I need to do the ontology and the
classroom and then one of the things
that I really want to do is compare how
do they carry the genes from the de novo
compared to the tuxedo analysis so
lastly I'd like to acknowledge Mike's
column from plant biology marine
handsome and Debbie from mvg also all
the collaboration with James Devon
owning we will appreciate that over lana
was the by fermentation that helped us a
lot with this she also taught me a lot
of mathematics so I'm really grateful to
him Lucas Miller we run all day all the
software for free basically in a huge
server at the bti so that was great also
the Cornell sequencing facility that did
a really good
and lastly I want to very specially
thank dr. new maxim so as he said I came
in 2008 and Elia was young and this is
in 2008 so this is the Easter ganic so I
just want to thank Neil for all his
patient or his mentoring group he's been
a great advice for someone really great
to work weeks and I'm basically mostly
grateful because she really let me
wander off pretty far away from his
owner of expertise so he was willing to
collaborate and learn with me which is
something that sometimes faculty members
don't do and I think his he's really
kind approach to do that enabled us to
build a stronger network connection in
in Cornell so the along wasn't it wasn't
even in the map at this point the only
weird thing about Neil I have to say is
that he likes to think in really strange
places and this is one of them so I when
I first came I thought maybe was an
American thing but I realized that no it
was new but anyway he always even even
in these places he were to talk about
our research and I always was
procrastinating and lastly I also want
to thank my girlfriend Amanda for all
her support and in of course her dog and
this is the last slide I also want to
swing at the Horticulture Department
very much for this great six years also
soho for supporting six years as well
and all the biology different bio tas
that have done over the last four years
that I've been here actually professor
Turgeon is here who runs this bio and
thank you thank you for everything and
if there's any question I'm happy to
answer that
is that seventy percent of your unit
jeans math to bacteria do you think it's
because the petunias were infected with
certain diseases or glassy guess it
doesn't report see whether those vector
in jeans yeah that's really person
there's always some percent of
contamination with authority I don't a
nutter look something where I'm from the
deep growth across my party maybe when I
RNA structure on in capturing futility
us did you find any human gene like
suggesting yet hey the very beginning of
their coffee wasn't a slide showing the
general response mechanism spores or
soft stressed
our SOS one and sodium for the anti
Porter those two genes are among the
upregulation was what it was and sodium
proton and recorder okay yes this was
one piece of work but both are
upregulated and a sorceress and when you
find them in New York all you can find
it I'm sorry actually no and that's a
good question in the other part is that
the two innocents it's the model that
you believe east and south to trinity so
you think that after 24 hours to start
seeing damage but you'll see if you can
see the articulation of these days so if
you wanna see something extrusion bags
here you have exposed class to locker
248 96 hours
series
do
how long is it going to take provide
come up with
Barbara
that's what we put into our sorry it was
a long time because our as I said a
functional characterization is equally
as important as that Ric so let's
identify a mobile companies that may or
may not be suitable for you smarter
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu